what distinguishes you from from the
other candidates are there policy
differences or is it more about
electability and how you would Implement
those policies even if you agree on them
well I think what we've been able to do
in Florida is two things one we've had
unprecedented policy success all the
things that we believe as Republicans or
as conservatives for many many years
we've been able to take those values and
those principles and actually turn them
into reality every single day we put up
big wins on the board but we're doing
that while also enjoying major political
success you alluded to it we were able
to win re-election by a historic margin
over 1.5 million votes so as you can see
he doesn't actually say what
distinguishes him from Trump